[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Запоріжжя,
Подніпров'я та Запоріжжя]
Тут от фрагменти, які знайдені на березі Дніпра.
По найдрібніших можна знайти
маленький шматочок кераміки
[Олександр Шкаліков
Кераміст, скульптор]
і по ній відновити всю посудину
й дізнатися звідки вона приїхала.
Оце ручка амфори, верхня частина,
от я просто зараз можу
її домалювати,
тобто вона мала ось такий вигляд:
от тут ручка, тулуб —
і була вона з денцем ось такого розміру.
А це, всього-на-всього
маленький фрагмент.
Тому те, що зробила людина з глини
і потім це випалила,
залишається на сотні тисячі років
і це її відбиток у часі.
Ну от власне мене, так,
постійно дивує ця магія:
от людина бере шмат глини
і він такий...
От глина, так, потім з нього [шматка глини]
можна створювати щось.
Зараз зроблю.
Людину, яка сидить на краю,
і дивиться в небо.
Тут, в Запоріжжі, є така піч,
в якій опалюють
кераміку давніми способами.
Іноді приходять люди і я кажу їм,
що тут 1200 С°.
Вони не вірять: як це можна
дровами досягти такої температури.
У цій частині печі
відбувається процес горіння.
А там, трошки далі така невеличка кімната:
туди завантажуємо речі,
які зроблені з глини.
Тому що деякі люди кажуть, що це кераміка.
А керамікою глина
стає після того, як вона випалена.
Це [температура] 600–900 С° мінімум,
а в нашому випадку 1200 С°.
Оце об'єм дров,
можливо іноді трошки менше.
Це буде тіло,
дві ноги і дві руки,
і голова.
Є шматок глини і є оці деталі –
оце насправді людина.
Це майстерня.
Вона присвячена тому, щоб
тут щось створювати.
Це те, що зроблено на майстер-класах.
Останнім часом, я всім пропоную
зліпити ДніпроГЕС.
У нас скоро буде ціла колекція
таких от «ДніпроГЕСиків».
Хоча я цього хлопчика питаю:
«А що ти зліпив? ДніпроГЕС?»
Він дивиться на тата і питає його:
«А що таке ДніпроГЕС?»
Камень і кераміка — це не проблема
її знайти і зберігати,
а потім мені стало цікаво збирати
дерев'яні речі.
Або цей предмет.
Це мені випадково потрапив.
А зроблений він для того,
щоб набирати штукатурну масу.
Ось така платформа.
Це такий авіаносець, скажімо так.
Ну от не часто він вберігається.
Ось це така поодинока людина, — самітник.
Ну в цілому, ми ж всі поодинокі.
І з підошви береш шмат глини,
зліпив, висушив, в піч — випалив.
Ну це дуже круто.
У мене був такий досвід,
коли під час дощу, я йшов у взутті,
до мене прилип шмат глини,
я його відірвав від п'ятки,
зліпив пташку, потім цю пташку
посадив на дерево поблизу,
воно там підсохло, потім забрав,
привіз, опалив.
[собака гавкає]
Власне з каменів, які були виготовлені,
тут були зроблені мости,
будинки.
Ось музей, називається
«Каменоломні», просто неба.
Тут є мій номер телефона.
«Олександр».
«Для усіх охочих, залучатися
до розбудови музею».
Жодного разу мені не зателефонували, на жаль.
Поки що музей розбудовуємо
своїми силами.
І ми зараз підемо
до двох кіл,
там об'єкт, який ми називаємо «Два кола»,
або «Кромлехи».
Привіт.
Добридень.
Тут був пустир.
«Кромлех» — це з давньобретонської.
В археологів її заведено називати
«Коло з каміння», — «Кромлех».
Як правило, в усьому світі, ці «Кромлехи» —
святилища, вони розкриті на схід.
Ми розкрили на південь:
тут оці ворота розкриті на південь.
Велике коло, 12 метрів.
Там є ще маленьке коло,
воно розкрито на північ.
Сьогодні з трави зробили, трав'яний такий.
Ну це вже не «Кромлех».
Коло, воно розкрито точно на схід.
І ще сюди прилітає;
два рази всього чув лише, дві весни.
Тут є місцевий дятел-музикант, джазмен,
який стукає дзьобом по металевих конструкціях.
Це банда, це якась дивна штука.
Нещодавно ми знайшли гніздо шершнів,
яке вони зліпили з глини.
Потім загорілася трава
і це гніздо стало керамікою,
тобто це гніздо шершнів, це не людина робила.
Деякі знайомі мої,
вони люблять шліфувати все,
беруть наждачний папір
й все так шліфують і шліфують.
А я навпаки, залишаю сліди від руки
Ну, мабуть, достатньо.
Як збільшити критичну масу
свідомих людей, я не знаю.
Я намагаюся, але не знаю, поки що те,
що в моїх силах, роблю.
Це дуже сильна штука — думка.
Тобто якщо ми усі про щось подумаємо,
неформально,
то ми об'єднаємося цією думкою
і вона може бути реалізована.
Це схоже на хмари.
Тобто одна людина, дві, три, чотири,
п'ять, десять, тисяча людей.
Вони створюють хмару,
і тоді ця хмара може щось змінити.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Сергій Кучеренко]
[Монтажерка
Анна Воробйова]
[Музика
KASAЇ, OVERKO, Blooms Corda]
[Субтитрувальник
Олександр Шарма]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]